there are still sporadic protests on
Hong Kong streets but since the special
administrative regions parliament voted
in June against a reform of the
electoral law what became known as the
umbrella revolution has all that died
out Hong Kong citizens have no legal
rights anyway when it comes to elect
allure governing chief executive British
colonial rule came to an end in 1997
when sovereignty was returned to China
since then Hong Kong's chief has been
chosen by committee and in 2012 the
committee chose Leung chun-ying Simon
young of the University of Hong Kong
says the committee is padded with
members who are pro-beijing and so
trying to very much like the function of
constituencies and decided to keep them
because it was a very good way of
exercising influence over the political
system because of course these business
and the professionally leads they are
individuals who are very much concerned
about money and economics and and
therefore they help to promote the
economic stability of Hong Kong the
power of the political system can be
felt right down to the port of mahon
liked actual is a fisherman he belongs
to a powerful group in Hong Kong fishing
in agriculture comprise a mere 1% of
Hong Kong's gross domestic product but
the fishing industry has 60 members in
parliament
those members ability to legislate is
severely restricted if the fishing
representatives stray from Beijing's
line fishing rights could be cut during
the umbrella revolution liked action saw
firsthand what happens when they
irritate Beijing God hasta que pasa la
during those 70 or 80 days some hotels
had to close down there were simply no
more visitors arriving from the Chinese
mainland come that ala colleague mr.
Lascelles our fish to the hotel's our
business ground to a complete standstill
no one was eating fish anymore when
you've got fish and you can't sell it
you make losses that's the reality we
know how bitter that can be yeah Milan's
fishermen say everyone wants to eat fish
and any hint of democratization is off
the agenda for now anyway so why
shouldn't they at least earn money even
in the midst of political deadlock